well you know when he came to power
basic what he said is that we are going
to abolish all secular law and implement
the Sharia the religious law is the law
of the land
now can you run a country in the 20th or
21st century with laws that were written
in the 7th century it doesn't work
they don't according to Islam you cannot
have an interest rate in your bank
system so he basically he forbid all
interest rate and destroyed the banking
system he destroyed the economy you know
Iran that has so much oil needs to act
to import 60% of its gas because the
refinery are destroyed this this
revolution who made me promise to bring
better life now leave the the nuclear
issue leave terrorism leave the export
of revolution just focus on life and
this revolution brought nothing but
misery you know they they forbid the use
of condoms and when they came to power
there were 38 million Iranians today
it's 69 and a half it's imminent less
condoms more Iranians the revolution
failed but this regime was very very
smart when understanding that if they
are going to continue to be very strict
with religious law at the end the
bitterness of the people would do to
them what they did to the shop to the
king that they they topple so basically
not publicly but they gave up most of
the religious laws you can't have
condoms today and there is interest rate
Western music internet satellite
television even some freedom to the
press to release pressure to give a sort
of a democracy or pluralism to the
people while maintaining strong strong
control over a the list of candidates to
the Parliament and presidency and all
intelligence military and law
enforcement agencies these these are
these people are very they come they
might come it's very bizarre sometimes
like a man in a job with the oral visit
they are very smart they kept in power
for the last 30 years in spite of all
odds
in spite of a severe war with Iraq that
caused the lives of more than million
people in spite of intelligence services
of America and Israel in spite of
boycotts from the international
community in spite of internal
opposition they are still in power and
no opposition no real opposition
effective opposition is inside